welcome everyone um it is an absolute
pleasure to introduce our speaker this
afternoon
uh who is going to be part of our
distinguished frankie speaker series
um and our guest today is no one other
than carl zimmer
most recently the author of the book
life's edge the search for what it means
to be alive
but before i tell you more about carl
and
the many books that he has written and
the many ways in which his writing in
the new york times over the past two
years has enlightened informed and
taught us
about
the covet epidemic
uh how it's unfolding what we need to do
to protect ourselves and the evolving
scientific understanding
of the pandemic
let me start out first by saying a few
thank yous i'd first like to recognize
our benefactors mr and mrs richard and
barbara frankie
who have been
ardent supporters of interdisciplinary
activities at yale beyond the frankie
program in science and the humanities
we are deeply grateful to them for their
support of all the exciting
ventures that the frankie program has
undertaken over
since its inception
and i'm also delighted to report that
they are in attendance today so welcome
richard and barbara i also want to take
this opportunity to thank
thai camp for helping organize
this talk and all the series that we
have been holding so far and guy
ortoleva for his help with recording and
making these recordings promptly
available
and accessible to
uh many people beyond those who can join
us today
so we are recording this event so i
would like to request all participants
to leave their your videos muted for the
duration of the talk please go ahead and
submit your questions at any time in the
q a feature
on the chat um and we will
present these questions to carl at the
end
um so now um let me move on to telling
you a little bit more about our speaker
today
so carl as you all know reports from the
frontiers of biology where scientists
are expanding our understanding
of life and i mean life in the fullest
possible sense
and the new york times has
called him the country's most respected
science journalist
and many of you can also attest
to the fact as i mentioned before that
in the past two years what he has done
has been invaluable in helping us stay
on top of kove
he's been reporting for the new york
times since 2004 where he now writes his
wonderful weekly column called mata
and his writing has won many many awards
including the stephen j gould prize
which is awarded by the society for the
study of evolution
in recognition for individuals who
sustained efforts of advanced public
understanding of evolutionary science in
2021 he was a member of the team at the
new york times that won the pulitzer
prize in public service for coverage of
the covet 19 pandemic of course in
addition to his reporting
carl is the author of
14 books about science he's just
incredible he's
such a remarkable writer with his
insight with his
clear explanations i mean it's an
absolute joy to read his books and i
have to gush here that the first book of
his that i actually read was the one on
viruses which of course i re-read uh
during the pandemic
his latest book is life's edge the
search of what it means to be alive and
it's a notable book um
as picked by the new york times for 2021
it was the final finalist for the 2021
penn e.o wilson literary science writing
award
and so a little bit of his path he
started his journalism career at
discover where he went on to work for
five years as a senior editor he's
written for many other magazines
including the national geographic wired
the atlantic
and in 2003 he launched the loom an
award-winning blog which has been hosted
by discover national geographic
in 2015 carl became a contributing
national correspondent for start a
publication about health and medicine
where he hosted
science happens a video series that was
a finalist for a national magazine award
in 2019 carl zimmer created what is life
an 8 episode series of life
conversations with leading thinkers
about why life exists how it began and
other big questions about existence
he's a three-time award winner of the
american association for the advancement
of science journalism award twice for
his work on the new york times once for
the loom he's won the national academy
science communication award so the list
of awards just goes on and on and i will
sort of briefly truncate it and just
move on to tell you a little bit more
about his books
so um
in 1998 he published his first book at
the water's edge fish with fingers
whales with legs and how life came
ashore and then went back to sea and
since then he has written these 13 more
books for which she is once again you
know uh won fellowships from the
guggenheim foundation and the sloan
foundation
in 2018 he published she has her
mother's love the power perversions and
potential of heredity
the guardian named it the best science
book of 2018 and the new york times book
review named it a notable book of the
year he's also won the 2019
communications award
from the national academies of science
engineering and medicine and science and
society journalism award
amongst his
other
exciting books the one that
i have particularly loved
is the tangled bank and introduction to
evolution which was the first textbook
about evolution ever published intended
for non-majors
and
it was named an academic title of the
year one of the reasons i'm sort of
going through a map of his writing is to
show you his range depth and
versatility in terms of the kinds of
topics and the genres in which he has
communicated so effectively with various
sectors of the public
he also co-authored evolution making
sense of life which was now a textbook
for biology majors
and it was co-written with the
university of montana biologist doug
emlin
and this is a book there's a textbook
that is continually being
updated with edition new editions and i
think the fourth edition is now in
preparation
carl is a popular speaker at
universities medical schools museums and
festivals as you can probably imagine
high demand
and has also um you've probably also
heard him on radio lab and this american
life
so um he is um the only writer after
whom both a species of tapeworm and an
asteroid have been named
so um without further ado uh as you can
see i'm very gushy about uh carl's
writing uh i would like to turn it over
to call carl uh we are delighted to have
you here today
thank you so much priya it's really
great to be here uh thanks for having me
it's a and it's an honor to to be part
of the frankie lecture series
um i wanted to talk today
about uh about
life i mean as you indicate in your
introduction i i
life is kind of my as a journalist as my
beat as it were
and
but i wanted to sort of talk about life
um
in the big picture rather than um just
one particular fascinating aspect of it
so um let me just uh share my screen uh
i also wanted to thank the frankie uh
for um this poster which is just
gorgeous uh and um
it's you know sometimes you look at a
poster and you're like oh they picked
some weird photograph just to catch your
eye but this actually has a lot of
meaning for me and a lot of relevance to
the my most recent book life's edge
um because um
you know this thing that you're looking
at here um this is not uh
out of uh some science fiction movie
this is this could be out of your
backyard um this is an animal uh called
a tardigrade
and here it's being photographed on it
looks like a bed of moss probably maybe
grazing on a little algae
tardigrades are incredibly
common animals
but very weird animals and weird in a
way that's
actually like
helps us to to really think about
what what we mean when we talk about
something being alive like like a
tardigrade
um
so um
uh the um
so tardigrades you know they're
they're not visible to the naked eye
they're very small um they're they're
you you generally you need at least a
crude microscope to see them
and so um people didn't know about that
we're all surrounded by
tardigrades until the 1770s actually
there was a german uh
preacher
who named john august goes um i'm
probably not pronouncing that correctly
my french is my german is not great
um anyway
so
goes was a was a preacher who in his 40s
discovered natural history
uh and just jumped into it with a huge
passion
he actually
collected
he collected tape worms
and
he he had such a fantastic collection
that the the emperor of prussia bought
it from him
i didn't know that prussian emperors had
an interest in tapeworm collections but
this one did
in any case he also
saw at a friend's house
a microscope
and was immediately taken with it uh
microscopes had been in use for a
century at this point but you know
people were still using it to discover
new things and
he um
got himself a microscope this is
actually his microscope um and started
looking at stuff a lot of what he would
look at would just be you know water
from a you know a pond in his backyard
and things like that
um and
he really marveled at at this um you
know he he uh said a glass lens shows us
a new world and i know from experience
that you will be full of amazement when
seeing that for the first time
he was really quite taken with um
with what he was seeing
and one of the things that really
really impressed him
was uh
this
this is his
his own drawing of this creature which
we call the tardigrade
um
tardigrade
is from the french it means slow walker
but actually goes didn't call it that he
called it a water bear
he said strange is this little creature
because the whole organization of his
body is extraordinary and strange
uh and he said that at first sight has
the closest similarity to a little bear
this also led me to give him the name
little water bear
and then later he says one can hardly
imagine something more horrible than our
little creature appearing in the size of
a real bear
uh that would be quite something um but
uh in in this world uh water bears are
are quite quite tiny
um and so goes was was observing it
through his microscope and he he was
struck by these eight little feet that
it has
which are each armed with three claws
and
it was moving around
under the microscope
he wrote his movements i observed were
always the same he was on its back
continually stretching out and
retracting his feet as if he wanted to
try to grasp something to get on his
feet
so so here you have a naturalist who's
observing a creature in action um
the classic thing that naturalists do
with life
so now you know uh we're about 250 years
later and we know a lot more about
tardigrades we know that they are not
just
in ponds uh not just on moss there are
tardigrades in in the ocean there are
tardigrades all over the place and
they're incredibly diverse group of
species
and we can actually
watch them
walk not just be on their back flailing
their legs around but this is actually
uh one of the first movies of a walking
tardigrade
um and you know they're not that slow um
for their size
they move pretty pretty quickly on those
on those eight legs
so they clamber around um they are
they're animals that move uh and they
move towards things
usually they're moving to eat they're
finding something to eat whether it's
algae or some single-celled thing
and as tiny as
tardigrades may be
they have a remarkable internal anatomy
um
they're surprisingly a lot like us as
bizarre as they might
look on the outside
um sure they have you know they have
eight limbs instead of r4 but they have
a brain and they have a mouth and
they have a nervous system and they have
muscles even if salivary glands and so
on
you can see they have reproductive
organs as well
so here's here's yet another you know
feature that shows that they are like us
living things
um and you know living things uh you
know as a rule uh reproduced um this is
actually
uh a slightly scandalous video of
water bears uh having sex this is this
is how they do it
um the male transfers sperm to the
female um and then after fertilization
the
female produces eggs which it then lays
and then all those little eggs hatch and
now you have
more tardigrades
so you know i think we would all feel
very comfortable uh to
say that tardigrades are alive
i
doubt that there would be many people
that would dispute this
uh it just see it seems obvious i mean
we don't even have to discuss what we
mean when we say something's alive
and yet
um tardigrades
can do some remarkable things
that actually
challenge our
comfortable assumptions about life
so
if if
you were to uh become dehydrated
let's say you lost you know five percent
of uh the water in your body
you'd feel terrible you lost 10 you
would feel worse if you start losing 20
and more you're going to die that's it
you can't survive
um and if i were to pour water on you
after that you would not suddenly like
sit up and start talking um you're gone
you've died from dehydration
uh
that's not true for the tardigrade
so the
dehydration desiccation drying out
that's a regular part of being a
tardigrade um it's just that they're in
environments often where uh
where
they uh they're they are going to get
dried out
and when that happens um
they don't just become sort of a
shriveled version of themselves they go
through a very remarkable change
so this is an uh from an article an
american scientist from a couple years
ago so on the top it shows a regular
water bear
below it is a water bear that has been
dehydrated
uh and this strange little shape it's
called a ton t-u-n
and um
there's
there's nothing going on in there
you know
tardigrades
have to have to breathe
these don't breathe
uh tardigrades have to eat these tons do
not eat
they do not excrete waste they do not
move they they they look like a grain of
sand
and yet if you were to pour water on
that ton
it would swell up and it would go back
to looking like the tardigrade at the
top there
and you could wait quite a while
to do this
you could um actually you could wait
decades
and scientists have they have
stored away tons in collections
and eventually people have said huh
here's here's here's a tardigrade ton
that's been here for 30 years or 50
years
let's see what happens if we put some
put it in water
and more often than not they're able to
come back
and they really look very much like uh
just an ordinary tardigrade just walking
around eating just in a sense being
alive
and what's incredible is that this
capacity it makes uh tardigrades
unbelievably
tough
resistance um they can be blasted with
levels of radiation that
would kill any other animal many times
over
they've been sent into space actually in
this uh this little craft that was shot
into orbit
and
the the tardigrades that were sent up
there they were actually exposed to just
the the vacuum
of space
and they rode around like that in outer
space no spacesuit
and then came back to earth and then
scientists were able to revive them
again
so so these uh tardigrades are one of
the most extraordinary uh creatures on
earth and
you know so scientists are wondering
well how do they do this
how is this possible
it's a very complex process that they've
evolved
so the first step
is actually
to
to
avoid the damage that comes with
dehydration so the problem with getting
dehydrated is that all of our proteins
and our dna they really they really need
to be in water to work properly
and so once water levels start
dropping down proteins can get misfolded
there can be molecules that clump
together and um and things just stop
working
so uh tardigrades do this amazing thing
where they they make a huge amount of a
special sugar called triolos and they
basically um replace the water in their
cells with trealos and they can kind of
shrink their cells down
so this is part of the reason why
you know a tardigrade becomes really
tiny when it becomes a ton
but that's just the start actually so
they they then this diagram which is
really complicated is just reflects all
the things that are happening inside of
this animal's body as it turns it into a
ton
you see a little line there
vitrification vitrification you might
think of like glass and that's kind of
what happens actually that that
it makes a bunch of proteins that wrap
around
dna
mitochondria all sorts of different
structures
and freeze things in place and protect
them from damage
so essentially the the tardigrade is
becoming a kind of a protein glass
and you know like
so
if we think of of metabolism
for example as being like essential for
life
these tardigrades aren't doing it their
proteins cannot move they cannot react
with each other that's it
and they can stay like that in this
state
for decades
so
is the tardigrade that's become a ton is
it alive
well you know if we turn to dictionaries
for some help it's a little difficult um
so you have a definition here uh the
first one the quality that distinguishes
the vital and functional being from a
dead body
well what's that i mean it's almost kind
of circular you're saying that life is
something that living things have
okay
the second one is a principle or force
that is considered to underlie uh the
distinctive nature of animal beings
uh what is that
this principle it sounds it sounds
almost like alchemy
um
c is a little more concrete an
organism's organismic state
characterized by capacity for metabolism
growth reaction stimuli and reproduction
okay i mean we can get a you know
we can get our heads around that
scientifically
but um does a tardigrade ton
metabolize nope can't eat
can't produce waste doesn't do those
reactions they just do not happen
there's no water there to allow them to
happen can they grow nope perfectly
uh
fixed in in size the cells do not divide
because
they can't do metabolism do they react
to stimuli um well you know with the
exception of you know adding water
no they just
it's it's like it's it's essentially
like a grain of sand can they reproduce
absolutely not um
so
so we're left here with a very
frustrating uh situation where um we
have something that you know in its
ordinary form we would agree is alive is
life but can go into another state
uh a state that really does uh not fit
our definition of life
i'm so reminded of of uh you know all
the terrors that that humans have had
about being you know
buried prematurely
um this because people are worried that
they might go into some sort of um you
know deep sleep or or some some type of
state that would be mistaken for death
but you know in the case of of
tardigrades
it's
it's very similar in some ways to death
um scientists don't call it death um
they call it
cryptobiosis which means hidden life
so um so cryptobiosis which
other animals can do as well
is
in a way sort of taking life and sort of
tucking it away in a safe place
um but you know the fact is that um
by a lot of this
sort of standard
ways that we talk about life a
tardigrade can stop being alive and then
be alive again
the there's another uh uh example that's
uh
it's also really fascinating in a
puzzling way and that's viruses this is
a reconstruction of the stars kobe 2
virus which causes copen19
so if
if like me you've had covid you had
a billion of these things inside of you
uh replicating away
um
and uh you know
they're you know tardigrades are small
viruses are much much smaller
but obviously you know size
doesn't really take away from the uh the
power that they can have i mean this
this little virus
has turned our whole world upside down
has has wrecked
global economies killed
probably killed about 18 million people
so far worldwide um and uh
and
aside from you know the very practical
specifics
of what viruses do to our lives
um they're really very puzzling in and
of themselves like what are these things
are they alive
we couldn't even begin to ask these
questions until uh people had found
viruses
um because viruses are so much smaller
than tardigrades it took even longer for
people to be aware that we're surrounded
with them that they're inside of us
um so tartar grades were found in the
1770s
it was
viruses really weren't recognized uh
until
for about a century later a little over
a century later
obviously you know there were diseases
like rabies and influenza that made
people stick but you know people
couldn't say
that's a virus that's causing it that's
that's that's something that belongs to
this class we're going to call viruses
it actually
it actually wasn't a human virus that
was the first one that was discovered it
was actually a plant virus
tobacco farmers in europe were dealing
with a disease
called tobacco mosaic disease
and it would cause these splotches that
gave it its name kind of like a mosaic
and uh
so some scientists like martinez
martinez buyer inc um
figured out how to do an experiment to
understand what was causing the disease
you know they thought well
maybe it's a fungus or bacteria
because by the late 1800s
the germ theory of disease was becoming
pretty well established so
so what they did was they would uh mash
up
a sick tobacco leaf
and mix it with water
and then pass it through a filter
so that you know that big
clumps of stuff couldn't get through you
just only small things could get through
and they would inject it uh that that
fluid into a healthy plant and then they
would see that actually that plant got
sick as well
so that suggested yes there was some
kind of germ that was causing this
disease
so then biorink actually
used
another filter a very very fine filter
one that was where the pores were so
small
that
bacteria and fungi could not get through
so we did the same experiment again mash
up belief mix it with water pass it
through a filter now he's got something
that really just looks like water
and he takes that and injects it into a
leaf
and
lo and behold the leaf gets sick
so he's saying well there's something
else out there something other than
bacteria and fungi
i'm going to call it a virus so this is
the first time the word virus is used to
describe these invisible
agents of disease
couldn't see them you know it's not like
he was uh goods looking through a
microscope at his little lovely little
water bears he just
he could see the effects of the viruses
but they were too small for him to see
uh
this
this remained the case
for for decades and the viruses remained
invisible scientists were now able
though to to conceptually
understand viruses and could then look
for human viruses
like for example uh
uh influenza
and um
and so still though you know the
microscopes of the early 1900s while
they were much better than the ones that
goes had in the 1700s they still just
weren't powerful enough to see a virus
so wendell stanley had this interesting
idea
he knew that you could make
crystals out of different substances
you know we're familiar with salt
crystals but you can actually make
uh crystals out of proteins too they
under the right conditions they'll come
together in this sort of
some repeating pattern
and if a crystal gets big enough you can
see it you can shoot x-rays at it and
figure out its structure
so i thought well you know there's some
indication that that viruses have
protein in them so
why don't i make a virus crystal
so he
he grows a lot of tobacco mosaic virus
in tobacco plants
concentrates them
and then
he sees lo and behold that these little
spiky shapes start to form
they start to become big enough that he
can see them with the naked eye
and he can collect these and store them
just you know on a shelf in a jar
and it's kind of like cryptobiosis he
can like take them off the shelf months
later and
you know put them in water and let them
infect a tobacco plant and they cause
just as much disease as before
so
so
this idea that
something that
seems like it's alive
can be a crystal
like like salt
this is kind of mind-blowing uh and when
uh stanley published his results
you know the the journalists
reporting on this really had a hard time
uh
keeping their composure
um so the new york times you know they
would talk about this how this staggers
the imagination
the viruses that are neither dead nor
alive
kind of like a tardigrade ton
and they seem to lie in that shadowy
shadowy borderland where matter is ready
to leap into life which is a line i just
love
the the subject really just for years
kept
obsessing people
and actually in 1940 a few years later
uh there was another article um
which had a section it was that was
headed can crystals live
and they talked about stanley's
experiment and they're asking were these
crystals alive apparently no no more so
than diamonds glass sand or other
crystals with which we are familiar
yet when virus crystals were put on a
tobacco leaf the mosaic disease spread
like a slow fire over a whole field just
as if it had been infected by
living bacteria
so
so very early on even before we really
knew very much at all about viruses
people recognized that they posed a huge
challenge to our concept of life
so finally microscopes caught up with
the viruses so electron microscopes made
it possible to actually visualize
viruses for the first time this is what
tobacco mosaic viruses look like
they have this interesting cylindrical
shape
what's inside of them what are these
cylinders made of well rosalind franklin
who might be best known for her work on
the structure of dna
before that had actually made a name for
herself by studying tobacco mosaic
viruses and actually doing really
important work to figure out what are
these things made of what are viruses
made of
and it turns out that
that a tobacco mosaic virus is made of
protein here the blue and violet show
different proteins that are kind of
locked together
and
they hold
genetic material
in the case of tobacco mosaic viruses
that material is
rna
we keep our genes in dna which is a
double strand um there's some viruses
that also have double-stranded dna
but a lot of them a lot of viruses have
rna for genes instead that's one strand
so
covid19 is caused by an rna virus the
flu is caused by an rna virus
tobacco mosaic disease is also caused by
an rna virus
but what's really interesting here is
that it's just this protein is it's just
a package
and
the it's just carrying these genes it
doesn't have it doesn't even have
contain enzymes that you need to copy
the genes like we have it's just a
delivery system
now it turns out that that shape of
tobacco mosaic virus is
not
the rule for for viruses
and
as you can see here
in this diagram you have viruses that
are
like soccer balls
some some are like snakes some look like
you know weird little spaceships
uh they're they're all very small um but
uh
but they but they have this incredible
variety um
you know there could be literally
trillions of species of viruses on earth
we don't know we
we barely scratched the surface when it
comes to their diversity
but in spite of all the diversity there
are a lot of things that unite them um
in some ways have you seen one virus
you've seen them all
again in the sense that they're not
the viruses are not like cells
so they're not
little chambers full of metabolism going
on inside
a
you know a cell can grow a cell can can
divide a cell can copy its own dna
viruses can't do any of that um they're
just a they're a protein shell
with
genetic material inside
and sir peter matawar
a famous immunologist of the 20th
century said that they were simply a
piece of bad news wrapped up in a
protein
that's a good way of summing up what a
virus is
so
what this piece of bad news does is
infect cells and get the cells to make
more bad news
in other words
the protein shell will have receptors on
its surface that can let it latch onto a
cell and
deliver its genes inside the cell
and the cell's own machinery reads those
genes makes proteins
and those viral proteins basically take
over the cell
and caused the cell to make new viruses
which then escaped the cell to go in
fact infect other
cells
so
just you know just with the real basics
there of what a virus is and we have the
question again
as we had with tardigrades and their ton
is a virus alive
now i showed you the the dictionary
definition before
scientists actually have you know
will uh come up with their own
definitions of life
um and i would say uh that the most uh
influential
is one that a group of scientists came
up for now came up for came up with for
nasa sorry about that
in the early 90s
they they were having a meeting about
exobiology about finding life on other
planets and they're like wait we need to
agree on what we're looking
for right um
and so they had a
spent all day arguing over this argued
over dinner and by the end of the day by
the end of the evening they have
settled on a working definition
i write about this whole process in my
in my book life's edge
i said life is a self-sustained chemical
system capable of undergoing darwinian
evolution
so short sweet clear
good you know good good writing um
and as i say very influential like you
you will see this definition or versions
of it around a lot so we have these
viruses
um
darwinian evolution that's a big part of
the definition
they certainly are
um you know we're dealing with the
omicron variant of uh of cyrus kobe 2
right now
variants are produced through evolution
through mutations through natural
selection
so
so now you know omicron is is
far more fit
than the first viruses that emerged in
china it has evolved a lot since it
became a human pathogen
so
no question that viruses are capable of
darwinian evolution they're they're the
textbook case cases
however
what about being a self-sustained
chemical system
well there are chemicals in it obviously
but self-sustained you know in the sense
of like being able to feed itself to
expel ways to maintain an internal
environment
nope
can't do it it just doesn't do it
so
here we have something that straddles
the definition which meets the
definition halfway
is it
half alive
uh can can we have such a thing
um
gerald joyce is a scientist who uh
helped to come up with his definition
and wrote about
how they came up with the definition
later
and a reporter was asking him about that
experience and and brought up viruses
and
joyce said to the reporter
according to the working definition a
virus doesn't make the cut
so sorry viruses
they're not alive
now
when i have when i talk about this in my
book or in in lectures
um
scientists sometimes will reach out to
me and they'll say
well of course
joyce is right i mean viruses are not
alive i mean they're just they don't
have
the those essential things
that make life possible
and then i will also hear from other
scientists who say well this is
ridiculous of course the viruses are
alive you can't understand them
without thinking about them as evolving
living things
i literally got two emails in the same
day
where i was being told that viruses were
and were not alive from scientists
so this is still a live wire issue
i think one of the most intriguing
ways of
addressing this and challenging joyce is
comes from someone named patrick forte
he's a french virologist
and he
you could kind of think of the
viruses
according to forte a little like the
tardigrades
in the sense that like
tardigrades can be in two different
states
so you've got the regular tardigrade
walking around and then you've got that
ton
so a virus that's floating around
outside of a cell
think of that as kind of like a ton
it's got
you know genetic material inside and so
on but we wouldn't really
not really alive but once it gets inside
of a cell
things are very different
it's not so much the virus itself that's
alive but it's it is the
merger
of the virus and the cell
so an ordinary cell
forte calls it a ribose cell and that
it's because uh they have ribozyme i'm
sorry ribosomes which are these
factories that they use
to make proteins
based on their genes
but the cell is making proteins for its
own needs you know if if thing if a
cell gets
hot you know it can make proteins that
will help to protect itself against heat
um it can make you know proteins to uh
stick on its surface to to grab
different kinds of uh things that it
needs to survive
so
a pro a cell you know can can look out
for itself as it were
now once a virus gets into a cell
as i mentioned before also there are all
these virus proteins inside of it
and these viral proteins
completely change what what the cell
does
in the case of covid for example if you
get covid
uh
the cells that are infected with starch
cov2 inside your body they can no longer
make their own proteins
the the virus proteins plug up those
ribosomes and they only let virus
genes in virus rna can go into the
ribosomes
so it's like it's like the worst you
know uh bouncer at the club door um it's
it's not going to let in
our rna it's only going to let in the
viral rna
and so
so in other words the cell the cell's
purpose the cell's function has changed
and he calls it a viral cell and in that
regard
for terror says viruses are alive
you know and it's it's easy to sort of
to uh
to
to miss just how much a virus changes
the cell once it gets inside so i
mentioned it plugging up those ribosomes
here the viru the ribosomes are shown in
purple in this computer image of an
infected cell
but
these yellow things these are actually
represent bubbles that the virus creates
inside of an infected cell
so the cell is full of these bubbles and
inside of these bubbles gets
put
new viral rna
in other words genetic material for new
viruses
it gets it builds up inside of these
little nurseries and then
it gets will later then get packaged
into new viruses to leave
so again like if you look inside of an
infected cell a viral cell it just
doesn't look like an ordinary cell it
looks like a different kind of life
and so forte who has a knack for the
poetic says whereas the dream of a
normal cell is to uh produce more cells
the dream of a virus viruses to produce
100 or more new viral cells
now
i don't know when this debate's going to
end
and i'm not sure maybe it can end in the
way that people
are are conducting it
um and
to to sort of explain what i mean i want
to just jump back again uh to the 1930s
back when viruses were a deep deep
mystery
norman peary who was a british
virologist who did a lot of important
work on on tobacco mosaic virus and
other viruses
he wrote he wrote about this exact same
question
he said when one is asked whether a
filter passing virus is living or dead
the only sensible answer is i don't know
we know a number of things they will do
and there are things that it won't and
and if someone will define the word
living i will try to see how the virus
fits into the definition
so periscope recognizes that
we are
we are
trying to pretend that there is a
a a scientific a clear scientific
question to be addressed
without recognizing that the language
that we're using to frame the question
is actually really
problematic in some ways
uh you know if someone will define what
living means to me well gee you know
i gave you the nasa definition of life i
gave you the merriam-webster definition
but there are lots of other definitions
um
uh these are actually like taken from
the scientific literature
um and these are just a a tiny sampling
there are hundreds several hundred uh
published
definitions of life different ones
and more get published every year
so you know so if norman perry was
waiting for someone to give him a very
clear definition of life that he could
work with does figure out if viruses are
alive or not
well you know
80 90 years later we're
we're still waiting for
that kind of clarity
and maybe that this buzzing confusion of
definitions tells us something
that's the argument that carol cleland a
philosopher at the university of
colorado has made
and
she she wrote a book a couple years ago
called the quest for universal theory of
life where she lays this out
she lays it out as a philosopher
and the the key point that she makes is
that
we should not
be searching for a definition of life
in fact
definitions of life get in the way
of our understanding of life
and that might seem weird i mean
how can you
how can you understand study something
that you can't even define that sounds
like
mystical
but it's actually not
the the problem is that uh
definitions
philosophically speaking
are our ways of organizing concepts and
you know cleland points out that you
know let's say what is a bachelor you
can define a bachelor
because all you're doing is you're
relating
different concepts to each other so a
bachelor
is an unmarried man
well what does it mean to be you know
that
there's no question about that
now what is marriage well
that's complicated you know but as a man
that's complicated too
and so um
so there there are things that that that
can be easily defined cleanly to find
and things that are much more
problematic
and
if you focus on
trying to find just the perfect
definition you may
not be spending the time you need to
really understand what it is that you're
dealing with
so an example
of that that she gives is water
okay so
what is water how do you define water
well 500 years ago if you went and
talked with alchemists you know they
were the ones who understood
what we call chemistry best and they
would define it for you as as being
transparent as being liquid
as being able to dissolve certain things
they give you a list of characteristics
but that was very problematic because um
for example what happens when water gets
cold and suddenly you have a solid
is ice water well
no not according to the definition
then you would have these different
kinds of
transparent uh liquids
that could dissolve things but some
could dissolve some things and some
could dissolve other things so are they
all water
alchemists would try to
deal with this by calling some things
royal water for example
which we would know to be certain kinds
of acids
even leonardo da vinci at the time was
just left to mystify by water so you
would talk about how water was sometimes
weak and sometimes strong sometimes
bitter sometimes sweet
sometimes thick or thin
sometimes bringing hurt or pestilence
sometimes health giving
so it's it suffers changes in as many
natures as are the different places
through which it passes
so so eve so
so
you know trying leonardo da vinci would
not have gotten any greater clarity just
trying to come up with a definition of
life
what was needed was 300 years of
research of experiments of thinking
and and
theorizing and coming up with a
theory of matter
in which you could explain water
so once you have the the language of
atoms molecules elements and so on
you can think about water uh
in terms of h2o
and you can think about water as
being molecules in motion and at certain
temperatures it becomes ice so yes ice
is water sure of course it is
um
and
this is you can you know it's not so
much that you're you're seeking to
define water now you're just trying to
understand it you're trying to to see
how water behaves in different ways and
make predictions about it and so on and
you use it in interesting ways that you
hadn't expected before
so this is the difference between a
definition of life and a theory of life
um we don't have a theory of life but
what would it be like well it would
it would be a way to explain how matter
takes on certain properties um and we
could
debate over what those properties are
but you know what i like is the analogy
with super conductivity
over a century ago scientists discovered
superconductivity it was very weird
there were these these substances that
lost their resistance to the electric
current when you got them very cold
didn't make sense
einstein couldn't explain it richard
feynman couldn't explain it but
eventually some folks got together and
made a theory of superconductivity a
theory that explained it in terms of
pairs of electrons
and now it made sense now you can see
how different substances could uh
actually be super conductive uh and that
then allowed people to start making new
kinds of superconductive material um so
and you could you know start making
things that could support trains for
example um so so it's what it's a theory
that we need a theory perhaps about
you know organization and information
maybe that's something that that really
is what needs to be explained for life
just to give you
one example uh there's a theory called
assembly theory
that lee cronin at the university of
glasgow has been exploring
so it's not about the specific specifics
of dna and protein
but just about the steps that it takes
to make
molecules
so maybe what's distinctive about life
is that
life and only life can make
certain molecules that require lots and
lots of steps of assembly
and you know that uh it's a simple idea
but it's actually potentially a very
powerful one
because
maybe you don't need to know in advance
what living things are made of on other
planets
you don't need to be just looking for
dna based life maybe there's you know on
a moon like enceladus
over at saturn maybe life is totally
different
maybe assembly theory can help us to
understand it
and you know it's possible that you know
maybe life isn't going to be discovered
on another planet maybe
someone in a lab was going to make it
these are little droplets of mixtures of
oil that actually cronin and his
colleagues have have produced
just mixing different things around you
get
droplets that do weird stuff um they he
refers to them as unstable protocells
they move around they divide
they do life like things
they're very strange i don't know we
quite call them life but
they might be
telling us something about how
living things first arose
and we could use theories to uh
to understand
what we're looking at
but this really you know this really
takes us back 250 years because you know
when
i think when we're looking at these
amazing experiments like what's
happening in this dish
i think we're kind of like goes was you
know where he talks about a glass lens
that shows us a new world
um i think you know
uh
that we in a sense are looking at life
for the first time um with this new
perspective and we're just beginning to
under to maybe to be understanding it
and in this new and profound way
so thank you so much for for your time
there's
lots more about these issues in in my
book life's edge uh and i'm more than
happy to
take questions if people have them
thank you so much carl for that
wonderful talk outlining the
complexities
of
the semantic definition of what life is
because of the biological chemical and
other properties that we attribute to
life forms
and you know this is a question that's
of great importance even in the space
sciences at the moment where people are
trying to understand
if we do discover
signs of extraterrestrial life what
might that look like
and there of course we may have to even
expand beyond the idea of carbon-based
life where which is where we are
fighting over the definitions on earth
thank you so much for that wonderful
talk so let's uh
give
carl um
a clap a virtual clap before we open up
for questions
so um i think we have a few questions
that have come come into the chat
the first one is from shauna
who would like to hear your thoughts on
the theory of symbiogenesis
taking more of a center stage in common
knowledge and the future role of
quantum mechanics in explaining
questions in biology
uh wow well great questions yeah um so
so uh symbiogenesis uh is this
this idea of
different organisms um or different
living systems coming together in a
symbiosis to create new
levels of life
so for example you know the the best
example would be um in our in our cells
we produce fuel in mitochondria
and those mitochondria are
basically are our little you know uh
little house guests um they're bacteria
that
took up residence inside of
our single-celled ancestors um
maybe uh i guess about two billion years
ago something like that
um and
um
there was a
there
there was a mutual benefit there in the
sense that the bacteria were
getting shelter and they were getting
some provisions and then they could they
could actually produce
things like
like atp
fuel for the host cell and eventually it
became
impossible to distinguish that the two
of them there there became
uh just one greater unit
um
and uh you know the when people like
lynn margulis were arguing for this in
in the 60s it was it was fairly uh
controversial um it wasn't clear how
important it was but
you know along with mitochondria there
are lots of other examples
whether you're talking about the
chloroplasts that make plants green or
actually you know insects
insects and other invertebrates have
lots of bacteria inside of them
the bacteria actually inside of their
cells and can only live there and they
have this remarkable
symbiosis so like
cicadas for example which you know we
have these you know these emergence of
cicadas and um
you know the cicadas are eating uh fluid
from from trees and you know there's not
much nutrient in it um and on its own
the cicada couldn't survive on it but
you feed that to the bacteria that it
harbors and the bacteria can actually
build essential amino acids and then
give them to the insect
and so you have a symbiogenesis right
there as well
i don't think that semiogenesis will
necessarily tell us that much about the
very origin of life
just because um you need those
complicated things to begin with
to have them to come together you know
bacteria already pretty complicated um
but it is possible to think about you
know people think on the early earth
you know
the earliest life forms might have had
rna ins inside of them or maybe just rna
floating around in
sort of oily layers at the bottom of
ponds or something like that
so you could have different rna
molecules cooperating with each other in
a kind of
molecular symbiosis that's possible
as for quantum mechanics um
you know i i mean obviously like when
you get down to the level of atoms
quantum mechanics matters um
i
[Music]
i don't know i mean ever since when i
started as a science writer over 30
years ago
people were talking about the revolution
of quantum mechanics to change the way
we think about biology um
and um
you know it's important you know if
you're understanding like vision and you
know for example in levels of energy
levels of photons and so on but
um i don't think that
i haven't seen
much yet in how quantum mechanics really
changes the way we think about
important kinds of biology or principles
of evolution but we'll see okay i could
change
so somewhat related to that carl i had a
question so i mean our view of in our
view of evolution right it's very much
driven by this idea of competition
and so as you just mentioned right so
isn't there and sort of an emerging
understanding now on
competition and cooperation both being
elements of how evolution actually
operates
sure and you know
you know darwin was was intrigued by
cooperation um
from from the very start of of uh
evolutionary theory um i mean he
certainly was aware of the importance of
cooperation
um
i think that uh
i mean
basically you know there are
situations in which cooperation is going
to be the the most uh
advantageous evolutionary strategy and
they're going to be situations and for
certain organisms where it's not
um
so you know
when
you know when co when stars cov2 is
infecting us for example um and you get
mutant
variants popping up inside your body
there is a competition going on among
those viruses
it's an unconscious competition it's
it's not like a race or something it's
just like the question is well which
which mute which the viruses with
different mutations which ones will make
the most viruses
um and
you know
they it's and then over the long term
you know the the mutations that increase
the fitness of viruses the most may
become the ones that are dominant
uh on the other hand you know the the
fact is that viruses this is kind of
weird but viruses do sometimes cooperate
um they actually
work together to to uh you know
different kinds of viruses will get into
the same cell at the same time and
manipulate it together using their
pooled resources to to make more of each
kind of virus so um you know that's
you you're still getting sick um so that
cooperation isn't very warm and fuzzy
for you the sick host but you know it's
pretty cool that the viruses are
cooperating as well so they're they're
both definitely important uh for
evolution
great thank you
so we have a question now from dt
pradhan who runs the famous tilde
science cafe and her question is where
would one place viruses on the tree of
life
um great question yeah so the tree of
life
was this uh this image that darwin
invoked in the origin of species
because he saw s
species as
sharing a common ancestor evolving
splitting off from a common ancestor
like like branches on a tree
and so we share
an ancestor that lived maybe six or
seven million years ago with chimpanzees
we share an ancestor that maybe lived 10
million years ago with gorillas those
are our closest living relatives
and you know for animals like you can
make a whole tree like you're showing
how animals are all
related and descend from a common
ancestor there was a a primal animal
from whom we all descend and that's all
animals that's tardigrades and jellyfish
and sharks
all of us
and if you step back further
um
you know we share a common ancestor with
fungi
and if you step back even further we
share a common answer register with
plants so
we're closer cousins to fungi than
plants that's something that's worth
bearing in mind
uh
step back even further and you can start
to see how we're related to protozoans
and then to bacteria so all of cellular
life can pretty
pretty well be
organized on a tree of life looking at
their genes and comparing them
then you got viruses what do you do with
these things um
how are they related to if at all to
anything else
the pro part of the problem is that
viruses are so small and they have such
tiny
uh
genomes that there's just not that much
information
to
to link them to anything
so it's very hard to know i mean you can
tell viruses are related to each other
but it can be very challenging to link
them to the rest of life but
there are
some clues as to how
you know
genetic material
from
cellular life may be able to break off
and become viral
uh and uh you know in fact we you know
it goes the other way as well that you
know we have been infected by viruses
our ancestors for millions of years
some of that viral dna has been
incorporated into our genome
so we're about uh about eight percent of
our dna comes from viruses
uh so um
it's possible viruses were there at the
very beginning of life maybe viruses
started out as parasitic rna we don't
know
so
um
so you know so viruses may sort of like
hover around the tree of life maybe
that's the best way of thinking of it
thank you um i think um
you've definitely um you know shown us
the paradoxes of you know how we could
deal with the viruses so the next
question is from agata which of the
definitions of life wrestling resonates
most closely with you and why
um
yeah no like it sort of depends on the
day
um
they're um
you know i i
i write about uh the creator of one of
those definitions in the book uh named
albert zen gorgi
he was a hungarian nobel prize winner he
won the nobel prize for discovering
vitamin c basically
and
once he had won the nobel prize for
vitamin c then he decided well okay now
i can get down to some really serious
work and so he really wanted to get down
to the very
nuts and bolts of life really like life
itself on a
on a sort of biophysical level
and
he he did amazing work he uh he actually
uh got
he was in hungary and and
was
starting his research right when uh
world war ii breaks out
he he becomes a spy
he joins the resistance and he's just
he's on the run
um
around hungary but he'll show up every
now and then unexpectedly in his lab
to make sure the experiments are going
okay
where they're trying to understand how
muscles fiber muscle fiber works because
he really feels that that's going to
give that
the key
and then
he actually then smuggles it out he get
he gets a swedish diplomat to smuggle
out
the manuscript about these findings
because um he's terrified that no one's
gonna know about what they found
and uh you know a lot of people think
maybe he should have gotten a second
nobel prize for that but
you know that it
he he joked afterwards
after that work and after the war that
you know he was working so hard to
figure out what life was but it was just
sort of it kept
escaping him
and um
and
after a while he was just like well you
know i'd like to call i call life a play
of water
um because he was interested in the way
in which you know a lot of the key
reactions that happen in a cell involve
water molecules you know being broken up
and and and being used to carry out
these reactions
so he just said life is just a play of
water so i can live with that
so um the
other question the next question is even
from mother sudan who says even
self-sustaining living systems
cannot be a closed system they need
external sources of energy
if you put things in that way is a virus
that different they need external matter
to exhibit other signs of life
and they're asking for your comment yeah
no that's a very interesting point um
you know we
i think in biology there's been a
very long-running division between
parasites
and uh
quote unquote free living
hosts and um
it's
you know i
but you're right like i mean who is
really like totally free living like i
mean we we depend on other living things
um you know we we
we all carry around a microbiome we'd be
very sick without it and so
um
so i i agree that that it's uh you know
we can't be too contemptuous as it were
of viruses
but i still think that you know the fact
remains that
you know viruses you know
are really different than cells and in
some fundamental ways
um
and but who knows you know scientists
are finding some really weird viruses
these days like really big viruses with
lots and lots of genes and some of those
genes seem seem to encode for parts of
cells you know like ribosomes or or
parts of the
apparatus for uh photosynthesis so
there's
there's there's some weird things about
viruses i'm sure we'll find viruses that
really you know defy our easy
definitions even more
thank you thank you
so there's a comment uh from gary who
says you know what is life
the question needs a context and who is
asking and in what domain
and the important issue is knowing the
mechanism as to what is going on in a
particular domain and then you can
assign terms
either new ones or old ones uh to
different parts of the process
uh to further experimental work
well you know certainly um
you know
it helps to uh
it can be useful to have working
definitions of life
for for particular
uh
work
you know the working definition so you
know if you if you want to go and find
you know alien life and you're gonna
spend hundreds of billions of dollars
trying to do it you know like it might
be nice to be able to know what it is
that you're
even thinking about finding but
even then you know i i talked to an
astrobiologist
whose it appears in the book lori barge
and i said to her you know so he she's
enceladus which i showed before this
moon of saturn she'd really like to go
to enceladus
because it's got a very it's got covered
in ice
but it clearly has a lot of weird
chemistry happening inside of its liquid
ocean
and uh and i'm like well what's your
definition of life like what would it
you know what would it have to be in
order for you to say it's alive and
she's like
i prefer not to deal with things like
i don't like to define life
you know this is literally an
astrobiologist you know whose job it is
to find life she's like i you know i
like to go there and
see what the chemistry is and and i bet
it's very interesting
um and i'll just want to understand what
what it's doing and what makes it
interesting and you know maybe
eventually we might come to agree that
there's something there we call life but
i you know what if it was you know
chemistry that
in in in 10 million years
will give rise to life you know like you
wouldn't want to just
dismiss it out of hand before so
so it's interesting even astrobiologists
sometimes don't want to define life
thank you carl um the next question and
is from brian are there genetically
similar creatures to tardigrades if so
do they display the
cryptobiological process
so um so tardigrades are just they're
animals they're they're
um you know they're i forget what their
scientists are always trying to figure
out how and closely different parts of
the animal kingdom are related to each
other so
i think they're
i think they're kind of closely related
to insects as i recall now but you know
they're their own branch but
yeah so they share a common ancestor
with with other animals like us
that have you know brains and guts and
nervous systems and so on
um
now uh cryptobiosis
what they're able to do
is actually found in a number of animals
um
lots of you know lots of little
invertebrates that do it
and fungi and bacteria seem to be doing
something similar as well so um
what's interesting is that
you know i showed you the the tardigrade
strategy which is essentially to like
just uh replace your water with sugar
and then turn your body into basically a
protein glass that's one way of doing it
other
branches of the tree of life have
evolved other strategies to do the same
thing
but
the result is the same that these things
are
somewhere between life and death and can
stay that way for decades as far as we
can tell
great um the next question is from diane
so since prions lack genetic material is
their consensus that they are not alive
um
again you know it all comes down to what
your definition of life is
and so um
you know
they are they are again kind of like uh
you know they're at life's edge you know
they
they they might fulfill some parts of
the of common definitions of life and
fail others um so for example so prions
are proteins
just naked proteins
but
they they are sort of deformed versions
of proteins that we make ourselves
and so if a prion version of the protein
comes up next to a regular version it
can deform it as well so now that's a
now that we call that a prion
and then that can deform another protein
and so on and so forth so that can lead
to diseases
like
mad cow disease that people
have gotten from from eating
contaminated beef
or lamb
deer suffer from a prion call chronic
wasting disease which is a big problem
tear hunters are aware of that
but again it's just a protein that
it can
can it reproduce well
you know it doesn't make a new protein
from scratch
neither does the virus you know
the
you know all the stars cov2 in the world
is made by us you know it's made of made
out of human
molecules and so you know it's sort of
weird that we think of this thing as a
virus but it's manufactured out of human
parts
um
so i don't know um so so is is is making
some one another molecule take your
shape is that what we call that
reproduction uh it's it's
it's very hard to say and yet it has
some lifelike properties so again
it's not really the answer isn't
maybe we shouldn't be thinking sort of
either or i know we like to think of
life or death something's alive or it's
not but
we have these very fuzzy cases that are
that are interesting because they're so
fuzzy
right
thank you so the next question is from
stephen who asks
it seems that exceptions have been the
most helpful in trying to establish a
rule
how do the characteristics of
mitochondria support or fail to support
their candidacy for life especially
given their supposed origins
yeah so
um you know i could have spent uh you
know the hour talking about mitochondria
instead of tardigrades and viruses
because they're here we have another
fascinating example our
our mitochondria alive
now i
i
we probably all agree that that their
ancestors two billion years ago were
alive
in the sense that other bacteria
floating in the ocean
are alive
they they were
you know they were able to metabolize
and reproduce and evolve
what's kind of amazing is that actually
inside our cells still
um mitochondria
divide
uh you know when
to
they're sort of like doing their own
thing
um
the mitochondrial division and cell
division are kind of tied together but
not totally so you know different cells
have different numbers of mitochondria
in them which is
which is interesting
so they're still doing part of what we
think of as being alive
but the fact is that if you look under
the hood if you open up
mitochondria and look inside
they still have some
genes
i forget the number something like 30
genes so they have some dna inside of
them
and
those
genes produce proteins that do
incredibly important things you know we
get really sick if those genes are
mutated
um those genes you know descend from the
genes that were carried by free living
mitochondria
but
you know the the g those mitochondria
had uh
thousands of other genes
so where'd they go well some of them
were lost they just didn't need them
anymore
some of them actually ended up getting
moved from the mitochondria into our own
chromosomes
into our own dna
so we have some and along with a viral
dna we have some bacterial dna in there
as well
so
so you have this thing like if you take
mitochondria
and pluck them out of a cell and just
put them in a petri dish and say like
okay
on your own like
they're they're dead they can't do it
they um
and yet
there's nothing more
important to our own life than
mitochondria you know you you shut
mitochondria down we're dead you know
some of the most potent poisons work by
shutting down mitochondria
so
i you know
i have no idea if you call mitochondria
alive or not
it's really up to you but it's really
interesting to think about how it
compares to things that we
are more comfortable calling alive
um thanks carl i think
true to
your book's title right there are many
questions that one can ask about the
edge of what counts as life and
how we define that edge but before we
close this wonderful session
it is too tempting to let you go before
asking you what do you think is coming
next
with the covid
with our pandemic are we are we in for
another
minor wave
wave unnoticeable wave noticeable waves
well you know we're two years into this
pandemic and
you know i find that you know the
the smartest scientists i talk to are
also the most humble um they really uh
respect this virus's capacity to
surprise us
nobody nobody saw you know omicron for
example
coming like no one had said like we're
going to have something like gomercran
until we had omicron
so you know people keep saying like oh
that's it we're done oh virus has always
evolved to get milder or or oh the virus
has
run run as far as it can go and
i honestly don't think that we know that
or not and that's not a happy
that's not a happy
thought
given all the suffering that it's caused
us already but
um
you know i this you know right right now
right you know today uh as we speak
there is this
uh sub variant uh
of
a sub variant of omicron called ba2
which is um
has become dominant most cases in the
united states are that
but cases are still pretty low in the us
and
it it's possible that this is going to
give us a bump but you know on the other
hand a lot of people
have already been infected recently or
they've been vaccinated so they may
slow you know uh rain that in
i don't really think we know i mean we
will know in a week or in two weeks
about this one
but you know my question is what happens
in six months um yeah
you know it seems like every six months
or something you know we get an alpha
a delta an omicron a really big thing um
are we going to be due for a new one um
there's certainly lots of viruses out
there that are evolving
so um
so there might be another one there
might be another one in the works and
you know if we're
if things work out
for us
our vaccines will continue to protect us
against it
um but
you know if we sort of dropped the ball
on vaccine development um
you know we could be looking at a new
form of sarco v2 that that our vaccines
are just not really good against so
um
it's been a long two years but i i just
don't i i see no reason to just get
complacent
gosh um
sounds like uh we need to be conscious
and this pandemic uh could just ooze on
its way out
and maybe i guess the um well let's not
uh leave it on a pessimistic note
we might have this uh with us forever
but um
anyway thank you so much carl for taking
the time
to talk to us today and
thank you for all the wonderful work
that you do um
making um the science
in particular during this pandemic
intelligible to the rest of us
so um so on behalf of the frankie
program and our audience today i'd like
to give you a big warm thank you
thanks so much for having me it's been a
lot of fun
and thanks everyone for attending we
have a couple of events coming up next
we are going to continue virtually on
zoom through to the end of the semester
and we have
our next talk on the mapping series uh
which is coming up which is by the
musicologist victor coelho
and then we have two talks coming up by
our own frankie fellows um
frankie graduate fellows um
in uh in april as well so we have a rich
program uh for next month the
mapping as knowing lecture series talk
by victor coelho is on tuesday april
12th
and the talks by our frankie fellows
anna florence and diego ellis soto
are on april um 19th sorry april 20th
and dates to be decided further later in
april anyway uh i would like to thank
everyone for attending and look forward
to seeing you at the next events
and um
thanks again carl bye